Robert Hardy is an actor and author the
recipient of honorary Doctorate degrees
from reading Durham and Portsmouth
University's he has played for Stratford
seasons two old Vicks seasons and
starred in many plays in the West End
and in America dr. hardy is a commander
of the most excellent Order of the
British Empire a fellow of the Society
of Antiquaries consultant and trustee of
the Mary Rose trust and has served
several years as trustee of the Royal
Armouries of the Tower of London he has
acted in a number of films including
Paris by night war and remembrance Sense
and Sensibility mrs. Dalloway the tich
born claimant and for Harry Potter films
his work on television includes David
Copperfield Little Dorrit all creatures
great and small and Winston Churchill
the wilderness years he recently played
the title role in ITV's Churchill the
hundred days that saved Britain dr.
hardy is the author of longbow a social
and military history now please join me
in welcoming dr. Robert Hardy
mr. president madam president and all
those kind people who've been generous
and welcoming to a starving Britain
really I should spend most of my moments
which are now going to time with a watch
large enough for me actually to be able
to read I should be spending most of my
time saying thank you to all of you kind
generous and unusual people who have
welcomed me and my godson who I should
be thanking because without his help I
would not have got here but I think you
probably want me to talk about other
matters as well don't wear two pairs of
specs at the same time that's better I
would just like to say that I'm about a
quarter of the way through your
presidents latest book called
Churchill's farewell no sorry no no no
Churchill's trial and it seems to me
that it is so far as I've read and I've
done a very great deal of reading about
Winston Churchill through the years that
it is the very best understanding of
Winston Churchill and his Winston's
overall understanding of the past
and his own present and his value for
today for any future that may develop
and I must also thank because he
he's been my friend and we're both
highly honored by HM the Queen in the
same measure Richard langworth and his
wife Barbara because they have carried
the banner from years long ago chiefly
in the marvellous magazine the finest
hour which goes across the world and he
was among the very first to say what
Winston left behind to the world must be
preserved examined re-examined all the
falsity and all the rumors and the
untruths that are told about him must be
corrected he has done and he's doing a
very great work apart from what he's
engaged in here which I'm sure you won't
all know about now about fifty years ago
I heard on the radio a professor
predicting that within 25 years from
then our two nations that both speak
English would be mutually
incomprehensible now I think that's
wrong although of course there are
versions of our shared language on
either side of the Atlantic of the
Atlantic which need translation even to
native inhabitants having spent many
happy years in this mighty country of
yours I have heard and read some of the
finest purist use of our ancient
language which will hardly surprise you
there are exceptions of course being
myself a countryman and brought up among
animals
I have often bought me a hen and as
often that hen has pleased me but
however long and hard I have tried I
have never know our Nara persuaded a
British hen to go shimmy Shack shimmy
Shack although I know that in this
country of yours that is how the hens of
the US of A expressed themselves for now
I just hope that my accent and usage
will not prejudice you or your
acceptance of the few words I have the
great honor of having been invited to
offer you but first a very very brief I
promise you word of autobiography which
I think might interest you I was at
Magdalen College Oxford we pronounce it
because were like that maudlin more than
College Oxford twice once was in the end
of 1943 in 244 where my tutor in college
was one CS Lewis and my university tutor
in anglo-saxon was another one j.r.r
tolkien so I felt pretty lucky both were
a joy indeed but I had to leave them and
report to the royal air force in my
country as a volunteer trainee fighter
pilot and I was sent immediately for
that training to Texas
it was because all the airfields in
Britain were chock-a-block jam-packed
full of American and Allied airplanes
and what a time that was for us 30 miles
east of Dallas a little village called
Terrell loaned by your generous country
to the RAF and it was then a tiny tiny
place friendly welcoming and it had
rails all along both sides of the street
in front of what shops there were to
which the horses of the in comers for
the day would tie their months and then
go shopping and between Dallas and Fort
Worth I forget how many miles it was is
quite a stretch it was just rough bushy
countryside not anymore
we were spoiled welcomed fed sumptuously
after the privations of war timings and
we could hardly believe our luck and
eventually we returned home to await
demobilization because you had dropped
two atom bombs so as a result of that an
pass i was never sent in action against
the enemy thank you from the bottom of
my heart
I returned instead to Oxford England and
to the delightful care of CS Lewis and
rather overshadowing my academic duties
to my preparation for life as an actor
now I'm going to tell you this bowtie I
am wearing was one of Winston
Churchill's and one of the greatest
moments of my life was after about a
fortnight of filming at Chartwell the
Churchill country home Grace Hamblin who
was a very close friend and Secretary of
the then Prime Minister said I think you
ought to have this and she opened a draw
and produced this and said you're much
better than I thought you would be and
it was was a great great award and in a
way I've always regarded it as a kind of
token of forgiveness for my perpetration
'he's on the family and those others
close to Sir Winston I must talk a
little about him because he was such an
extraordinary man you've heard a good
deal about him this week already but to
me he was the hero and the savior of my
country he took us the nation by the
hand and led us through an abominably
unpleasant time when we stood alone and
he used to speak on Sunday evenings not
every Sunday but on Sunday evenings
before the nine o'clock news and
wherever we were most of the nation
would hide to the radio and the radio in
my household used to be brought to the
table my father's household
should say was brought to the table and
we listened while with total honesty not
pretending anything was better than it
was he would tell us in those early days
the most grievous and frightening news
but somehow he never let us collapse as
we listened and he never finished a
speech without in some fashion raising
our spirits holding them in his hands
and pushing us forward to a future which
would be bright he said and talked of
sunlit uplands and we used to see those
sunlit uplands in our minds I met by
great good fortune Winston Churchill
twice first time was in a club which my
father belonged to and for some reason
Winston was there very briefly and I was
presented to the man and I remember not
very much about it except that when I
got out of the club I felt an
extraordinary sort of energy almost
electric which I presume looking back
came from him and then they I'll tell
you a little bit more about the next
time I met him which was in the fifties
Richard Burton who was a great friend of
mine was playing Hamlet at the Old Vic
and I was in the company playing with
him and he grabbed me before the curtain
went up and said the old man's in front
come to my dressing room the moment the
curtain comes down because he's coming
to see us so there we were waiting in
Richards dressing room and we heard we
had already heard in fact Winston who
sat in the front row and whenever we've
got anything slightly wrong or made a
cut with which
was not familiar he would grumble land
his his grumbling of it was of some
measure as you probably know but there
we were waiting in hin this dressing
room and we could hear him approaching
done the corridor grumbling to somebody
who he wasn't really grumbling he was
just using that voice of his and he came
in and he said to Richard your royal
highness
I'm in dire need may I use your lavatory
and Richard sit across so it's there and
he disappeared and then he came back and
the first thing he said was thank you
your highness that's a great relief I
was intrigued by your Hamlet I thought
he was a very powerful young man and I
mused that he lasted so long without
killing his unpleasant uncle and then
after conversation and so forth we
escorted him down the corridor towards
the stage door and his waiting limousine
and he was met by an aide who came
towards him and looking rather shocked
sudden they said in a whisper Prime
Minister your buttons are still undone
and Churchill said one he said I'm sorry
Prime Minister but your flies are undone
Churchill replied immediately have no
fear
a dead bird does not fall from its nest
he was pretty flash with replies when
necessary I'm going to leap now ahead
because time runs to roundabout 1978
when I was approached on the telephone
by a great friend of mine a film
director called Ferdinand Fairfax those
of you who saw any of the wilderness
years this afternoon would know that he
was the director and he was telling me
what he was doing and asked what I was
doing as we used to do frequently on the
telephone and he said I'm doing the Sun
burden with this giant enterprise to
make eight hours of film the story of
Winston Churchill up to the war through
the wilderness years and I was simply
thrilled because he was talking about my
hero and I said oh my goodness me who's
gonna play him I really wanted to know
and he said we haven't decided yet so I
said I'll tell you what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna make you two lists one on the left
of people who I think in my wisdom could
present him physically and on the right
people who I know could approach his
personality via the voice so that's what
I'll do and he said very kind of you
thank you I'll let you know what I think
about those lists so time went by and
then he rang again and I said tell me
quickly who you've chosen because it was
very important to me to know who was
going to venture upon this mighty ocean
of playing Churchill and he said I mean
I too asked him he any of those on my
lists were those chosen was was
contained one who he chosen and he said
no we haven't and I said well who the
hell have you chosen because my list was
extraordinarily good
and at the top of the both lists was
Anthony Hopkins who I said should have
done it and I still say today should
have done it and should do it but the
answer they came down the telephone
we've chosen and we've chosen you and I
my response was not nearly as quick as
Churchill's would have been under
similar circumstances we've chosen you
had been Prime Minister oh well thank
you very much
I said you're mad you are utterly beside
yourself with folly the answer to it is
never never never
however they laid siege to me and
assailed my resistance time after time
and I have to say lunch after lunch at
very good restaurants and at one point
after a very very long lunch and a great
deal of flattery and misrepresentation i
feebly said well if that's how you feel
I'll have a crack and then things went
on and the first thing was to read the
original script that came in and it
unfortunately had been written by a
Scott a very famous writer a very good
writer but two things Millie did he
militated against him being adopted
finally one was that he was a Marxist
and the other was that he hated Winston
Churchill so he left by the back door
and another group came together which
was the director the producer and the
absolutely wonderful and amazing friend
of your presidents the great Martin so
they worked for they said you you'll be
free now for nine months and you will
have plenty of time is a good gestation
period
get it so I did and I had the great good
fortune to possess at that time all the
Decca recordings which I didn't review
ever come across them but they are
twenty five twenty four long playing
well flash and stuff of course but long
playing twenty minutes
sides which all adds up to something
approaching 500 minutes of undiluted
Churchill and I listened and I listened
and the hours went by and the days went
by and the weeks and the months and by
the time the nine months were nearly up
when it was so to say time for delivery
I really felt that because of hearing
him from his earliest days and the
hustings with all the high-pitched voice
throwing it over the crowds so that they
heard his political message to the final
recordings that he made of speeches that
were never recorded so my work listening
included all the speeches that were he
made on the radio some speeches that he
made in public and of course none of the
speeches that he made in the House of
Commons nowadays it would all have been
recorded and one could get out of it not
them but he recorded them for Decca and
he took a long time at Chartwell well in
his 80s recording those speeches who
with a much growly voice then he'd had
when he first made them in the House of
Commons and I became absolutely obsessed
by a sort of mantra the mantra at
listening to the flow of his voice and
then it wasn't his voice anymore it was
his thought and through listening to his
thought
I felt in the end that I knew quite a
lot about him that I had penetrated
quite far into his extraordinary
personality so I felt braver than I had
done and I was even able as a technical
achievement to tell what he had recorded
before lunch and what he'd subsequently
recorded after lunch because the tone
had dropped again and there were the
occasional you know of course that he
had difficulties with his voice and at
one time an advisor who his mother sent
him to to see if they could cure his
Lisp and his slight hesitation which
used to appear at times of stress even
right through his later life as Prime
Minister and this man said to him well
you're getting on all right I don't know
what you're worrying about
the only thing is you're obviously going
to do very well in life but just don't
take on anything and promise me you
won't
that requires speaking in public
so I leaped now to the first day's
filming which happened at Blenheim
Palace it was a windy day and the very
first shot those who who've been there
know that there's a wonderful pillar
with a statue of the first Duke atop
this giant pillar and the first shot of
the day was a helicopter shot of the
Duke and then the camera crept down the
column to this disheveled figure at the
bottom in an old overcoat in a hat and a
walking stick who then turned around and
walked slowly towards Blenheim Palace
his birthplace and that was me
pretending to be Winston but the wind
was up and the first thing I heard after
the words action was a frightful indrawn
breath of a crowd of people and looking
round which I shouldn't have done but
did I saw that the blades of the
helicopter were within inches of the
noble Dukes head but the pilot was a
smart man and the next thing I saw was
the helicopter tumbling away and then we
were all sent to have coffee or whatever
until the wind abated and I sat with my
back to the door of a sort of shack
beside the palace where a coffee was
being served in a padded overcoat with a
hat on a Churchill hat on and the next
thing I heard was a remarkable female
indrawn breath another one the second of
the day and I looked round and it was
one of Churchill's wartime secretaries
who were gassed thought she'd seen of a
ghost
we became she was
her name is on Slayer and she was a
great friend of mine baby not really
long after that that happened and we
finally got that shot done and a lot
more filming at Chartwell and it was a
very bad winter it was the winter of I
think 79 80 thick snow ice everywhere
crowds of the film crew in and out of
the house Chartwell and melting snow
inside everywhere and the kind lady who
had given me the Klan secretary who'd
given me this tie called it the rape of
chart for the are about presents there
and putting it back to the 30s and that
sort of thing but one day somebody
whispered in my ear
Mary Soames is here and I thought oh my
god I'm gonna meet her and we first met
each other in the hall between one of
Winston's I think best paintings of
flowers in a silver bars on the left and
his rack of umbrellas and walking sticks
to the right and she looked me straight
in the eyes and I tried to look her
straight in the eye and she said the
bowties about right he never could tie
them and the suits not bad oh but this
mess she said with real grief in her
face this is my childhood home and look
at it now I said would you like to come
to my trailer on the front lawn and have
a glass of whiskey and she said yes
immediately
so we went and she starts she opened up
a bit and at one moment she said all
sorts of nice and helpful things and at
one moment she sees my right hand which
looked like that with a ring like that
on it and said what's that what did you
get that and I explained that it was a
copy of the Churchill ring which I'd had
made by the crown jewelers with the
Spencer Churchill crests on it she said
extraordinary is that the sort of thing
that actors do and I said well if
they're sensible they do yes and that's
not the end of it I mean I went to a
dentist who knew about Churchill your
father's dentist and he knew about the
hole in the hard palate and he made a
plate for me so that I had all the time
something to conquer as Churchill had
himself she was amazed at that and we
got on very well the whiskey was the
winner the time went by and I suppose I
got a bit better at it from time to time
and then Ferdinand Fairfax director came
to me and said look here you never come
to the rushes those quick reviews the
day after of what we'd filmed the day
before I did not hadn't the courage to
go and see myself trying at home and he
said I've got a half-hour piece made up
of everything we've shot to date you are
going to come I said no no he said yes
you are I said okay bottle of whiskey
right I'll be there by the time that
escapade was over there was nothing in
the bottle left but I realized a great
sadness physically I thought I wasn't
too bad to look at simply but the voice
which I was so sure I'd gleaned from
those endless hours of listen
the vise wasn't there at all it wasn't
him at all and that defeated me and I
went to bed bed really very unhappy in
the next day we did the first shooting
scenes of Churchill at his stand-up desk
and I was to wear his embroidered
slippers and they had made them
specially in London for me but they'd
made them totally wrong they were like
boats they attached some elastic over
the top but I still fell out of them
and then one of the assistants at
Chartwell who looked after the place
came onto this sand stage and said there
are these and they were inscribed in
embroidered w s seed and I said may I
try them I was allowed to and they
fitted perfectly so that raised my
spirits no end was a very happy day I've
made seven or eight attempts to become
Churchill and never to my mind achieved
it at all but
the best was to come because years later
I was approached from Paris and I was
asked to play Churchill in a wonderful
play called silly with Giardino the man
who said no which was you may guess not
about Churchill but about what it was
but it was mainly the goal it was the
goal Churchill and the French Resistance
an entirely French company written by
two members of the Academy forces to
allows a la do go and Alipay Lafitte who
were both members of as I said the
Academy it was a magnificent script
absolutely wonderful then there was I
alone Englishman among the French a
dangerous position that had been tried
before and hadn't always been successful
sometimes it was very successful
Casey Poitier as a cool sir - but then
in the end they kicked us out as you
know and I've always been very careful
when talking to French audiences to say
I may mention some unfortunate
encounters of the medieval period but I
want you not to take umbrage because
after all there were only battles and
who won the war you did and this
extraordinary time in Paris was the
greatest time I ever spent on a stage
anywhere the play was quite wonderful
the production was unbelievable we
played it in a theater some of the size
of this auditorium but on a big break it
held 2,750 people and we wore tiny
microphones on our heads but you could
hardly see Ignis you were in the front
row and on it went and Mary Sam's had
said early on when you're in Paris I'm
coming to see you
she came twice in fact she said you must
go and see the new Statue of
it's quite the best it's in front of the
pitch ballet right at the foot of the
pile example you must go and see it so I
chose a moment when I was all not needed
on rehearsal jumped into a Texan and I
went and I could see this wonderful
figure among the leaves of the trees and
as I got closer I thought that's funny
because the whole of the great white
sock the plinth on which this lively
statue stood which had been opened a few
weeks before by our Queen and Mary
Soames was also colored brightly colored
red and as I got out of the taxi and
went up to it I was appalled to read in
still dripping heavy paint scarlet paint
las casas de mouth el Kebir
the murderer of the French fleet at Aram
and I took some alarm at that sight and
I went back to rehearsal and I said to
the great director I said this is rather
frightening he said oh you're right to
be frightened in forensic OHS you may
have quite a rough time when we open
you'll hear seats tipping up all over
the theatre the moment you come on
they'll recognize you as Churchill
because I wore the appropriate Churchill
thing which everybody recognizes black
cloud striped trousers hat and he said
they may be quite rude to you they may
shout at you they may they may throw
things at you
someone may shoot you
and I said what I did I don't want to
die I'm here he said oh but for an actor
what a way to go
that was Robert how they are saying one
of the great French directors it was a
wonderful experience that whole thing in
fact there was all the time rapt
attention in the theatre so good was the
play but it was tough for friends
elderly friends and relations of my
younger friends who used to challenge
shuttle 8 hated everything that he did
the sinking of the French fleet was and
when meristems came to the very first
time she said now say something about
the way you play that scene with the
girl about the French fleet you know
when that happened my papar was so
dejected muammar said that she'd never
seen him like that since the failure of
the Dardanelles when she thought he
would die as you heard from mrs.
Churchill yesterday and again they all
thought he was rarely at the absolute
end of desperation
so I altered the way we played that
somewhere there's another page I know it
yes no it isn't I was nearly going back
to the first page a bit of alarm drew
somewhat
the last little bit because times going
on and if you're rash enough to risk
questions
you're very welcome but I probably show
him to have the wit to answer them so
I've brought the speech that Churchill
gave in the House of Commons on his
presentation on his 80th birthday so I
could do that instead if you didn't want
to ask any question I've done it in the
House of Commons myself because I was
asked to but the final thing was because
I'm often asked do you think you ever
succeeded as Churchill and I always snap
no I know I didn't but I was filming
something else in this mighty state and
we were filming the meeting of Churchill
and Franklin Roosevelt on a British ship
the Prince of Wales but Chetan long gone
done to the bottom of the sea sent
courteously by the Japanese if you
remember but the your Navy had kindly
lent USS New Jersey a rather bigger ship
but very much on the same model and she
was in San Diego harbor and I was all
dressed up
the difference between playing Churchill
or trying to play Churchill in England
and playing it in the States is
miraculous in England I just shaved my
head back and had no makeup and said as
it were to the English public I'm
Winston Churchill and they said in their
manner go on prove it but when I got to
America for the first film about him
that I did here I was in makeup for
between five and a half and six hours
every morning
because they built Churchill on my face
and I was hidden in beside inside it
really unable to come out at all
but I did look like Churchill there was
no question I was dressed like Churchill
in the Trinity House jacket and cap with
all the right bits on it and eventually
they the American crew can call a man
came and said mr. Hardy we're ready for
you on the ship so I followed him down
the dockside past this majestic Clipper
brow and for all the world I wanted to
stay there looking at that all day and
not go on and a step further but when I
went and got to the great companion way
that led up to the ship's entry and
there at the top I could see two or
three extremely smart they dressed young
naval lieutenants and when I got to the
top the brightest of them stepped
forward and said and now this is how one
judges one's performance you see step
tall and he said to me no need to ask
who you are sir welcome aboard mr.
Roosevelt
thank you for your patience
now then the agonizing question do you
want to ask questions speech right right
November the 30th 1954 presentation from
both houses of parliament Westminster
Hall this is to me the most memorable
public occasion of my life no one has
ever received a similar mark of honor
before there's not been anything like it
in British history and indeed I doubt
whether any of the modern democracies
has shown such a degree of kindness and
generosity
to a party politician who has not yet
retired and may at any time be involved
in controversy it is indeed the most
striking example I've ever known of that
characteristic British parliamentary
principle cherished in both lords and
Commons don't bring politics into
private life it is certainly a mark of
the underlying unity of our national
life which survives when even grows in
spite of vehement party warfare there
are many grave differences of conviction
and sentiment this unity I believe is
the child of freedom and fair play
fostered in the cradle of our ancient
island institutions and nursed by
tradition and custom I'm most grateful
to mr. Attlee for the agreeable words
he's used about me this morning and for
the magnanimous appraisal eaves give
of my variegated career
I must confess however that this
ceremony in all its charm
and splendour may well be found to have
seriously affected my controversial
value as a party politician however
perhaps with suitable assistance I shall
get over this reaction and come round
after a bit the leader of the Opposition
and I have been the only two prime
ministers of this country in the last
fourteen years there are no other prime
ministers alive mr. Attlee who was also
Deputy Prime Minister with me in those
decisive years of war during our
alternating tenure tremendous events
have happened abroad and far-reaching
changes have taken place at home there
have been three general elections on
universal suffrage and the activity of
our parliamentary and party machinery
has been absolutely free miss jacket and
my monopoly of the most powerful and
disputatious office under the crown all
this time is surely the fact which the
world outside may recognize as a symbol
of the inherent stability of our British
way of life it is not however intended
to make it a permanent feature of the
Constitution I am sure this is the
finest greeting any member of the House
of Commons has yet received and I
express my heartfelt thanks to the
representatives of both houses for the
gifts which you have bestowed in my name
the the portrait
the portrait is
the powerful example of modern art it
certainly combines force and Kanda these
equalities which no active member of
either hearts can do without or should
fear to meet the book with which the
father of the House of Commons has
presented me is a token of the goodwill
and chivalrous regard of members of all
parties I'm very glad that mr. Attlee
described my speeches in the war as
expressing the will not only of
parliament but of the whole nation their
will was resolute and remorseless and as
it proved unconquered well it fell to me
to express it and if I found the right
words you must remember that I've always
earned my living by my pen and by my
tongue it was a nation and race dwelling
all around the globe that had the
Lionheart I had the luck to be called
upon to give the roar I also hope that I
sometimes suggested to the line the
right places to use his claws I am now
nearing the end of my journey I hope I
still have services to render however
that may be and whatever may befall I am
sure I shall never forget the emotions
of this day or be able to express my
gratitude to those colleagues and
companions with whom I have lived my
life for this super
honor they have done me
we do have time for a few questions
right my first oh good do you have any
comment on your experience or research
on the individuals who played the the
Winston Churchill decoys during World
War two they they the doubles yes
I thought I could reach this auditorium
I find I can yeah shock horror bring the
slippers I have no idea about how the
doubles were arranged I know they've
passed from time to time in front of
cameras do not know Richard no he's not
gonna give anyway I can't help you are
you is it easy to roll you're thinking
of occupying in the future we have time
for one more question
good evening sir wikipedia says that you
are one of the few actors who has played
both Winston Churchill and Franklin
Roosevelt I was just wondering if you
could comment on the differences between
the role and how you prepare to play
Americans I first played an American in
the West End in the Caine Mutiny
court-martial there were one or two
Americans in it particularly the lead
actor wonderful wonderful man whose name
because of my age I have now lost for
the moment it may come back I was
playing the rather spoiled young
lieutenant naval lieutenant from the
East Coast and I thought oh I can manage
that I was simply terrible I never could
do hours of that generation who could
not do American nowadays most of our
actors come over to this mighty country
and do a fair job as Americans I think
but I never could manage it at all has
that answered your question he hasn't
really could you repeat it
ofd are playing FDR yes of course
well a very different kettle of fish I
did try terribly hard and thought it's
it's possible because there's a great
deal of the English sound in it and I
studied Anglo second section as I told
you earlier and I could do better Anglo
Saxon for you but I don't think I'd risk
Roosevelt I did try and we did the great
speech after Pearl Harbor but not well
I'm afraid but I loved trying to look
like Roosevelt trying to embody him a
bit and when we were filming at
Chartwell
I used to take sit down periods when I
wasn't on the set in Churchill's library
well above the chimney-piece was a
wonderful painting by Salisbury Frank
Salisbury of Churchill one which he he
didn't really tell me like I think he
didn't like pictures of himself and I
thought why am I trying to play this man
looked like this amazing man when here
along the shelves is an Epstein bust of
Roosevelt I look much more like him
which was true in a way in those days
and so I felt and I did it in a French
film or tried it I thought oh this will
be alright but I Denny was very good but
I never think I'm very good actually
which is the right side of wisdom